[Music]
today all-in stick to football and stick
to football live
may the 4th be with you mellow and
Connor I hate myself for making that
joke but it has to be said not even a
Star Wars fan really AFC North class
breakdowns today we're gonna get into it
with some very good classes from the AFC
North don't forget leave your draft on
draft questions right here in the
Bleacher Report app right in that
comment stream leave your questions if
you like some of these question hit that
fire button we're gonna answer three of
them at the end of the show if you leave
good ones don't we're still gonna answer
three questions at the end of the show
we're here to follow us each in the
Bleacher Report app so you can get
updates on all the things that we're
doing here at BR and at stick to
football fellas we got mellow we got
Connor rocking a whale on his shirt he
looks amazing
it is good to be back together fellows
after a much-needed three-day weekend
look at Connor Connor summer ready I
feel like we just skip out spring all
together look at my guy boys i sat in
the Sun for the last three days and I am
feeling it right now is eliminate
heatwave here in the New York City area
but I'm ready to grade some drafts from
the AFC North I think one of our
favorite divisions when it comes to this
draft yeah absolutely we've talked for
years about the Ravens just draft
well Ozzie Newsome was the man one of
the best GM's of football he lines up
solo with John Harbaugh Ozzie just
grabbed drabs great well Ozzie Newsome
retired this is Eric de castas first
trapped without Ozzie by his side and
the student has become the master is
that a Star Wars thing I don't know it
was close look at this draft from the
Ravens mellow Akana you're each gonna
give a grade but Milla what is your
breakdown on this a plus draft for these
guys I think a lot of teams were
probably wondering what was gonna happen
after Ozzie Newsome and they still
nailed it and they even went after an
LSU guy like you guys mentioned on the
stream but I love what they did here and
getting a playmaker a running back like
they did I love Mark Ingram the guy
can't do it forever though these two
linebackers though Queen and Harrison I
think these guys are gonna complement
each other so well you see the speed
that Harrison has and what he can do in
coverage I think he's going to be an
exceptional linebacker in this class
he's able to seek his hips get back
there and you also have Harrison who's
good
be able to take away the run if you can
combine these two linebackers they would
be the absolute perfect linebacker I
love what they were able to do though
getting value at both these picks hey
you plus I think outside of the Cowboys
this is probably my favorite class in
the entire draft I'm with you Melo I
absolutely loved this trap for the
Ravens it felt like they kept hitting on
valued time and time again I don't know
how Patrick Queen made it to them in the
first round but he did and hope be a
star there but it was even the picks
after that I look at somebody like JK
Dobbins that can work that outside run
game with Lamar Jackson that's a perfect
fit Justin mad at bouquet is a guy that
gives you a pass rush on defense from
the interior of the defensive line and
getting back to Dobbins yes they have
Mark Ingram but this is the Ravens way
they're always a year early rather than
a year late so they'll run Mark Ingram
like crazy this year Dobbins will get
some workload as well but in 2021 this
run game won't miss a beat because
Dobbins will be able to take over as the
full-time starter they've done such a
nice job helping their young quarterback
in Lamar Jackson by good and by putting
good pieces on the offensive line good
pieces at the skill talent and once
again they reloaded on the middle of
their defense with Malik Harrison in the
middle of this group I think once again
when you look at Patrick wean and
coverage they have it all it felt like
the Ravens got a little bit of
everything in this draft and a lot of my
favorite players the Ravens last year
during the regular season there was a
hot esteem Lamar Jackson an MVP that
defense was nasty it's gonna be even
better the players you guys highlighted
they did great in rounds 1 2 & 3 but for
me it's what they did even late in the
draft and I'll go to round 3 getting
Devin Duvernay out of Texas such a great
fit with what you already have in
Hollywood Brown but now you get Duvernay
dropped one passing college the
downfield speed is there he ran every
route in the playbook at Texas he with
Sam Elgar's go tube guy if you're
watching the stream you can see the back
shoulder fades the adjustment to some
underthrown balls that he made Duvernay
is gonna be a playmaker in this offense
and on special teams
but then in round seven they've got a
hard hitter hard hit Harry is this guy's
nickname Geno stone from Iowa one of my
favorite of the day three picks in this
entire draft class you cut Tony
Jefferson
Chris Clark I think Gino stone has a
very good chance to make this roster for
the Baltimore Ravens I have to give them
an A+ it seems like they just do a great
job every year now the team trying to
catch them the Pittsburgh Steelers you
have to include make up Fitzpatrick in
this draft class they trade their
first-round pick
hey it's have change for him Melo the
Steelers they have some holes to fill
not a lot of pigs to do it I know I love
the move to get Myka Fitzpatrick but
when you look at the rest of the straf
class than what they got I'm not in love
with it I really like chase Claypool I
think that he can come in and be very
effective and I do think this is one of
the few teams that probably just gonna
play him at tied in and at slot receiver
and I love that pit but when you're
looking at the rest of it I don't love
it I'm giving this great a c-minus for
the Steelers I don't think you did
anything to really improve your team
you're really banking on a guy like Ben
Roethlisberger coming back and being
healthy I thought they might go and
target a corner even after getting Minka
in the trade or maybe even looking at a
quarterback of the future you have no
idea how Roethlisberger is going to
recover I think this is a team that
starts needs to start looking at a
quarterback every year until you can
find one late or spend a first-round
pick on them I think this is a team that
probably needs to look for their
quarterback in the future and that needs
to start right now well for how talented
this roster is I thought moving their
first-round picking getting what they
got out of make of Fitzpatrick was
phenomenal because let's be real guys
they were just gonna win a lot of games
and to get a player better than him was
gonna be very very difficult unless they
were after somebody like Jordan love
that fell to the back end around one but
when you look at the rest of the dress
yes it felt like it was a little early
for chase Claypool but this is a team
that develops pass catchers as good as
any in the league I really like Anthony
mcfarland EV running back for them it
feels like they just haven't had an
explosive option in the backfield for
quite some time and I mean even levy I
felt it was an amazing power back he's
got good agility he's a good pass
catcher but the actual acceleration that
McFarland has brings a different kind of
runner to this group with James Conner I
think when you even look at some of the
other picks I really like Kevin Dodd
in the fourth round I think he's a
future starter at guard so I think when
they you know for a team that didn't
have a ton of picks a ton of premium
picks I think they found a couple
players I think claypoole's gonna help
on special teams he's gonna help in the
red zone and going back to the whole
thing together with make a fitzpatrick
not the best trap but solid enough where
i give it a big big eyes when i look at
what the steelers did it's okay you had
a pretty good draft and you have a
pretty good roster but are you good
enough to beat the Baltimore Ravens did
you leave those three days and late
April good enough to beat the Baltimore
Ravens my answer is no you're still not
and the big concern for me would be if
Ben Roethlisberger goes down again we
just saw the two guys drafted ahead of
him Eli Manning retired Phillip Rivers
they don't want any more on the Chargers
you got no plan except for a guy who
gets punched in the face really well and
duck Hodges I don't know how you can go
into the regular season thinking we're
good here there's a team you should be
calling Cam Newton to get a number one
backup quarterback we see how valuable
that spot is so I like this draft I was
gonna mention Kevin Dodson Connor I'm
glad that you did I do think if healthy
he's a starter at the next level
I thought they went a little early on
Alex Highsmith and Anthony McPartlin jr.
actually their sixth and seventh run
picks I liked the best
Anton Brooks jr. from Maryland and they
Carlos Davis one of the Davis brothers
at defensive tackle from Nebraska so I
gave them a b-minus it's a good draft
but I don't quite know if you're ready
to take down the king of the north and
that is the Baltimore Ravens now don't
forget guys leave your draft on draft
questions we're going to answer those at
the end of the show just comment them
right here in the stream but today's
show is sponsored by State Farm with the
State Farm mobile app for roadside
assistance State Farm is able to assist
you
quicker than John Ross at the combine
and unlike John Ross State Farm will not
languish on the Bengals IR for years
that's just mean guys State Farm's
helped us so fast the State Farm was
confident enough to skip the combine to
focus on their pro day unfortunately due
to weaken recent circumstances
attendance at the pro day was scarce
causing many people to question that for
to to the State Farm reportedly rent
state farms the rare prospect that is
quick and fast
Thank You State Farm for supporting
stick to football I believe they're 40
to more than I do John Ross is 42 I
think we
just all agree he didn't actually run it
forward to to I'm never gonna believe it
it's like aliens a ghost you're gonna
have to show me or I'm not gonna believe
that it's real that was a rant I had
earlier today that you're now all
getting caught up on fellas we mentioned
John Ross we're gonna get to his team in
a moment but how about those Cleveland
Browns a year ago all the talking the
streets was the Browns were gonna be a
Super Bowl team Baker was an MVP the
Browns browned and they did not get to
that level Connor what are you thinking
about Cleveland's draft this year well
let's start with round one guys I
thought what they got in the first round
in Jedrek wills was simply the best
tackle in the draft so that's a slam
dunk to me which really elevates this
grade from the get-go now when you look
at the second round there's a little bit
more risk herein granted LP which grant
up but are we gonna get the guy that
looked like an absolute star is a
sophomore that can do a lot of nice
things playing in the box or the player
that didn't want to tackle anybody on a
championship team in his junior year so
that's what makes this so hard to grade
this trap I really like Donovan peoples
Jones that late in the trip Nick Harris
is a really ideal zone center and I
think that's the run game they're gonna
be looking to develop there so when you
look at the Browns trap there is some
risk but there's also a lot of really
nice scheme fits and impact players and
I'm gonna go out and say it
I actually think grant Duffy is going to
rebound so when I look at the entire
thing I give it a B+ the only problem I
had with this guy's
I'd like to Jacob Phillips and when I
said that I thought he'd be a nice sixth
round flyer they took him in the third
round and no teams I talked to you
thought he would go on the second day of
this trap so that surprised me a little
bit but whatever you took a pig on a
linebacker in that their round
overall it's a really good draft and
it's a b-plus for me yeah I really like
their draft too and I think a lot of
Cleveland Browns fans probably think I
hate their team
I just hate your quarterback I actually
really like you and your organization
and I love the pieces that you
surrounded me with Jedrek wills number
one tackle of my board and then you go
out and you get some other guys Harrison
Bryant I think he's gonna come in you
don't know what's gonna happen within
Joko and you add Hooper in free agency I
think this is a team that might actually
get to those 10 wins that we expected
last year I really like their draft I'm
gonna give them an a-minus I think we
grant Delta but there's a lot of upside
there
and him sliding to the second round I
think that puts a chip on his shoulder
and I do think we get sophomore year
great dealt but not junior year great
Delta man I hope so because this draft
would be an A+ if they get sophomore
year grant dealt but where they got him
if you can get software Donovan peoples
Jones as well who was your sixth round
pick this is the best draft of any team
in the NFL Draft now the key is they did
roll the dice on some injured players
grant dealt but will tell anyone who
would listen that he had an ankle injury
that caused his fault I actually thought
they reached on him based on how he is
2019 tape looked Donovan people shows us
another player who is banged up a lot
this year I like all these names the
problem is this with the Browns do and
you can go back and look at some draft
grades from me from like 2014 that when
they hit on my good players the brass
strap never works out it's some kind of
curse between the two of us
so I'm actually giving this a B+ I liked
that
we didn't see this become this
analytical draft where they trade out of
the number 10 spot where they trade out
of the second round they didn't do that
they didn't go with the Sachi Brown
approach this was more of a classic this
is how you scout players this is who we
trap even Jordan Elliott who they got in
the third round his penetration Adam to
zu as a three technique is really
intriguing to me I thought they hit all
their needs they checked all the boxes
but there are some swing or miss boom or
bust type players here that they drafted
that's why they get the B+ for me let's
stay in the state of Ohio though these
Cincinnati Bengals they had the number
one pick in every round of this draft
that start of a jobber o which was the
pick from December basically we knew as
soon as the Bengals earned the pick we
knew who was gonna be Conner you can
just kick us off here the great for the
Bengals how did you think they did this
year really liked what they did here
guys and quietly did very very well I
think I'm one of our shows last week
took we talked about how the Washington
Redskins come out they get chase young
and then they kind of lost momentum the
Bengals didn't really do that with this
draft you go out you get jobber oh
that's great he's their franchise
quarterback Matt I know you want to talk
about the connection with him and T
Higgins I really like that pick as well
well I want to discuss is really
bolstering solidifying the middle of
this defense which was so vital I liked
what they have
I'm backer you go and get a Logan Wilson
that can play Mike backer maybe hope
play strong side backer a three year
captain you don't hear that very often
and a productive four year starter at
Wyoming that's somebody that is gonna
really come in and be ready to go for
this defense there's really no learning
curve what you see is what you get he's
a throwback backer he's good against
stopping the run inside and outside and
then if you're worried about him running
and coverage with running backs and
tight ends they got a Kim Davis gather
from app stayed a guy that is gonna play
weak side backer he's kind of built like
a safety even though he plays in the box
a lot of speed a lot of good movement
ability so they got two really good
linebackers outside of those early picks
that can play right away that complement
each other very well I like what the
Bengals did and they earn this a - all
the way yeah and I'm giving this drafted
a plus as well I think they really hit
on all the positions at 18 I think
receiver might have been a little bit of
a stretch but you need to give Joe Broz
some targets you have a lot there we'll
see what happens with AJ Green though I
wouldn't be surprised if he's a guy that
moves on next year after that franchise
tag if they don't if he doesn't like
what's going on in Cincinnati and
another linebacker that they drafted in
the seventh round Marcus Bailey out of
Purdue I think this guy's not hurt we're
talking about him in the third round if
not how he was very good in the big 10
and I think that they can be a very good
team going forward a lot of people are
predicting that the Bengals will be
drafting in the top five next year I
don't know if they will be I think that
they are really in a good position
you get Jonah Williams coming back and
all the pieces from this draft class
they're looking very good this is an a
draft for me yeah I gave them an a-minus
I actually loved what the Bengals did I
know the first overall pick was a
no-brainer if you're watching us on
bleacher report in the bleach report at
backs you should be you saw Joe burrow
carving up everyone that was a
no-brainer I loved that they did not
trade out on Friday night say we have
the 34th pick let's get Joe Perot a
future target I think that this duo with
Tyler Boyd and T Higgins moving forward
no I'm not mentioning AJ Green I think
that do I'm moving forward with Joe
Burrell has the potential to be special
this could be one of the best
triangle offenses in the NFL Joe burrow
his ability to throw the touch and then
T Higgins soaring over defenders I
thought he was the best pure vertical
route learner in this draft class
another question is about speed my man
ran the same 40-yard dash is Michael
Thomas so I'm not worried about that
he can get down the field he can streak
with great routes and I'd like to what
they did the rest of this trap Logan
Wilson y'all mentioned it Kim Davis
Gaither Marcus Bailey you drafted three
linebackers three years we used to joke
about the Bengals they loved all these
old slow linebackers who aren't the
modern fit they just drafted potentially
three starting linebackers and even
Hakeem add energy in the sixth round he
could be a left tackle in the NFL I know
there's questions about he needs to
develop but the athleticism is
absolutely there so the Bengals get an
a-minus from me overall very very high
on what we've seen from the AFC know
from all three of us I'm gonna put you
guys on the spot real quick if you had
to pick one team right now May 4th to
win the north who's it gonna be
it's the Ravens still I think that the
Browns are getting close I think the
Browns will be better than the Steelers
this year but there's so much ground to
make up with the Ravens they're just too
good right now they're coming back with
a loaded backfield I really think
they're just gonna pound the ball down
everybody's throat and when that doesn't
work hit Hollywood Brown or Devon
Duvernay deep it's just very hard to
pick against Baltimore I mean when you
look at this barring some kind of crazy
injury there just read love relocked and
reloaded here guys I mean they got even
better you didn't lose a ton of players
in the offseason and I think their
ability to get mad you Don to play on
the franchise head you drafted very well
on the defensive side of the ball you
even got another playmaker two for Lamar
Jackson again and they're a well coached
team I listened the Browns like you said
they're getting there I don't know what
we're gonna see from Big Ben this year
and I think the Steelers are just as
talented as Baltimore when Big Ben is on
my question is will will he ever be on
again yeah also picking Baltimore this
one's easy was also easy checking out
what they do at gridiron Heights where
Dennis and crew are the best in the
business we got a little VP race action
for you
[Music]
welcome folks to the CMC good thing this
is a two minute episode let's all say
what we're thankful for is for yes for
war scene let's see ps4 starting at 199
homes is entering the race despite
missing so much time Patrick way ahead
Russ as a powerup
[Music]
no offense
you made it harder for me to win hey put
on some Creed now I have two we are in a
race thing cross what does he air always
say I'm only gonna stay in Seattle if
you dress better no not that the other
thing automatic supersonic hypnotic
funky fresh two more months of MVP race
coverage if you are not following be our
critter on Instagram you're missing out
on gridiron Heights all the other
greatness that they're putting out there
make sure you're doing that follow on
Instagram and right here in the Bleacher
Report app we have to draft on draft
questions because I threw my own end
asking you guys who would win the North
Sea Whelan 88 I think that's for Dez
Bryant Michael Irvin or CD Lam I'll let
you guys fair down which AFC North
quarterback throws for the most
touchdowns in 2020 and how many will it
be sounds like our guy is maybe planula
over under and it's just throwing the
football just so I think that eliminates
Lamar Jackson I'm gonna go with Ben
Roethlisberger on this one and I'll put
that number in about 30 33 now I think
the other quarterbacks are gonna be
pretty good but I think that VIN VIN
comes back in they're gonna have to
throw the football you saw what they did
with the running game last year you give
him a target like Claypool in the red
zone I'm gonna bet on Ben Roethlisberger
maybe not being very good this year but
throw-in for a lot of touchdown it's
easy to bet on Big Ben having the bounce
back Connor you're all with you got LJ
listen now I'm gonna go with Big Ben as
well I think when you look at the other
three teams they're just gonna run the
ball so much guys with Ravens we know
how much they run the ball the Browns
have gone out sure you signed Austin
Hooper but you also signed Jack
Conklin's you have plenty of running
backs there and you drafted a right
tackle with the top ten
I think the Browns are gonna run the
ball like crazy this year Baker Mayfield
had only 22 passing touchdowns last year
I don't know how much higher that number
gets Joe burrow is a sneaky pick but
once again he's a rookie so I'm gonna go
with the guy that's probably throwing it
would it be like 40 times the game as
long as he could stay healthy I agree
with Melo it'll be Big Ben I can't agree
with both of you guys I'm gonna take
Baker I'm also trying to mend our broken
relationship a little bit 8/3 27 as a
rookie I think there's a chance for a
bounce-back this year another 22 21
ain't gonna do it let me ruin it then
because I think that he will finish last
in the division I think touchdown to
Baker Mayfield every time I try to make
up to Baker Melo come I feel like he
like swoops in on my camera it's like
hey we're still Texas fans all right
last draft on draft question from G mark
teeny what is the deepest position so
far in the 2021 draft class
I know Melo has been working nonstop on
a draft 2021 tired what do you like so
far the offensive tackles I can't
believe how many offensive tackles are
in this class so far that I like
honestly I think they're about six that
could go in the first round
and that's Assaf right now I don't love
the edge rushes in this class I think
corners a little bit weak but offensive
tackle and again with the receivers
those are gonna be two very special
groups again in 2021 I was gonna say
tell me if you've heard this before but
it feels like the wide receiver class
again guys it's ridiculous and I don't
know if it'll be good as as good as last
year's I think that's a little bold but
when you look at Jalen Waddell the Bonta
Smith obviously Jamar chase and Justin
Ross those are the highlighted names but
people aren't talking enough already
about rondell more that's Maury and
Terry from Florida State as a guy that
if his quarterback could just throw him
the ball he gave Brice Hall a lot of
problems last year so I think this wide
receiver class is gonna be phenomenal
you have to sit wide receiver last year
37 drafted I don't know if we'll hit
that number that was that tied record
but the top end might be better Jamar
chase I think that's a chance to be
better than Jerry Judy CD lamb
Henry rugs the top end is going to be
exceptional how about tide in Kidd of
Penn State yeah it's a prior
Kylee Vince at Florida and then you've
got brevin Jordan at Miami tight end was
weak this year Cole come out first one
off the board mid round two I bet we see
a first round tight in oh I definitely
think so too I mean they call fryer
booth baby Gronk for a reason he's a lot
more than just a pass catcher the way he
moves he's more baby Kelsey yeah it's
running back I don't know if it's gonna
be deeper but you look at the top heavy
group they're not not very Harris
Travis 80 inch above Hubbard those are
three guys that probably could have been
in the mix and that round two of this
year's class now they come back and I
think that they can all three maybe
maybe even be first rounders we do not
sleep it stick to football we're already
on to 2021 and a little spoiler for our
friends right here in this very apt
Tuesday morning my first big board for
the 2021 NFL Draft drops we will be back
right here Wednesday at 5:00 p.m.
Eastern as we break down the NF C North
probably not much Mitchell's biscuit I'm
sorry Barry's fans follow us on Twitter
at stick to football I am at NFL Draft
out at mellow and at Connor Jay Rogers
don't forget subscribe to six football
wherever you get your podcast did your
Spotify Apple pods all the amazing
podcast networks for the gang we'll be
back Wednesday see them yeah you got
intro
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]